ever had a dream since you were a child
but you couldn't let it go
welcome to ireland once upon a time
there were two farms the mount loon farm
where rosemary lived and right down the
road
was my farm where my son anthony
asked his lonely question of the stars
why did you make me so
rosemary muldoon yeah be sotted
with love there's these green fields and
there's us
whatever that is it holds me here
[Music]
it's not normal i don't care you take
after john kelly and that man was mad as
the full moon
drowned himself he fell in he had a rock
tied to his neck brush me
we're known to each other quite a while
now would you marry me
are you going to leave the farm to
anthony i don't see a clear path
from where to where from me to you
my cousin is coming what do you think
it's the finest car i've ever seen
enough for the farm to an american
waiting for that one
what are you waiting for me i don't wait
i do like that
you should come to new york sometime
anthony will never marry if it comes to
that i'd freeze my eggs you should
freeze your whole body
if you're waiting for that one
[Music]
you ever had a dream since you were a
child and you couldn't let it go
so you put this gift between us is your
dream made you happy or miserable
you kissed him it was he that kissed me
that's what's got him worked off
i don't understand you people why do you
make everything so hard you just
seem to accept these crazy things i
don't like your fights well who does
half of ireland just not me if my true
love
we're gone i will surely find another
anthony time is running out
what is love is it a quest what are you
doing the madness
how many days do we have while the sun
shines it's not shining
i believe that it is
[Music]
go